[Música]
fin a la policía de la moral en Irán así
lo anunció la fiscalía general de ese
país en declaraciones recogidas por
medios locales esta ha sido una de las
exigencias del movimiento Popular de
protesta que inició hace tres meses tras
la muerte de la joven Max a mini bajo
custodia policial y que ha dejado entre
300 y 450 muertos
Indonesia evacuó alrededor de 2000
habitantes de la isla de Java en
inmediaciones del volcán semeru que
entró en erupción esta madrugada las
autoridades decretaron alerta máxima en
la zona en donde el año pasado un evento
similar dejó al menos 50 muertos
inicia la segunda fecha de octavos de
final de la Copa del Mundo en Qatar
Francia Polonia Inglaterra y senegal se
disputan este domingo dos cupos a los
cuartos de final una fase para la que
Argentina y Países Bajos ya consiguieron
su entrada tenemos el reporte de nuestro
enviado especial
Esta es una nueva actualización de
noticias en Francia 24 bienvenidos Soy
Daniela Blandón comenzamos en Irán donde
la fiscalía general anunció el fin de la
política de la policía de la moral que
desde 2016 vigiló los códigos de
vestimenta basada en la ley que reimpusó
el uso del velo después de la Revolución
islámica la decisión es vista como una
concesión hacia los manifestantes que
por tres meses han resistido a la
represión de las autoridades tras la
muerte de la joven maxa mini bajo
custodia de esa cuestionada fuerza
Samuel Salgado nos cuenta más
una decisión histórica en un régimen
teocrático el fiscal general de Irán
anunció el fin de la policía de la moral
la policía de la moral no tiene nada que
ver con el poder judicial y ha sido
abolidada Por quienes la crearon
un intento por sofocar tres meses de
protestas dentro y fuera del país que
dejan al menos 450 fallecidos luego de
la muerte de la joven kurda masamini
bajo custodia de esa fuerza por no
portar bien el hiyap
Irán también anunció que revisa la ley
que desde 1983 exige que las mujeres
porten el velo y sin dar detalles el
presidente ebrahim Racing habló de
flexibilidad en la implementación de la
Constitución
los fundamentos islámicos y republicanos
de Irán están arraigados
constitucionalmente pero existen métodos
para implementar la Constitución que
pueden ser flexibles
Según la ley a partir de los 7 años las
niñas deben usar el jiyab y todas las
mujeres desde la pubertad deben cubrirse
la cabeza y llevar ropa holgada en
público la policía de la moral
patrullaba las calles de Irán desde 2006
para hacer cumplir el código de
vestimenta Y aunque fue reformada en
2016 ilimitada a reportar infracciones
sin tomar decisiones definitivas ni
castigos en septiembre este año más a
mini fue arrestada y golpeada lo que
según grupos de derechos provocó su
muerte tres días después en un hospital
de Teherán dejando en evidencia casos de
violencia similares pese a los recientes
anuncios los manifestantes convocaron
para el lunes una huelga de tres días
con el objetivo de mantener la presión
sobre el régimen de los ayatolas
y no muy lejos de ese país en Siria
docenas de manifestantes enojados por la
crisis económica asaltaron la oficina
del gobernador en la ciudad sureña de
sueyda y prendieron fuego a partes del
edificio una persona falleció hubo
intercambio de balas y los medios
estatales dijeron que fueron quemados
archivos y documentos oficiales más
temprano más de 200 personas se habían
reunido alrededor del edificio pidiendo
la salida del presidente bachera lazada
y el volcán en semeru ubicado en la isla
Indonesia de Java entró en erupción esta
madrugada las autoridades elevaron el
nivel de actividad A4 Ese es el más alto
de la escala de alerta Lo que implica
peligro para zonas pobladas también
fueron ordenadas evacuaciones de unas
2000 personas en la región en la que el
año pasado la erupción del mismo volcán
dejó al menos 50 muertos y miles de
desplazados
hemos preparado escuelas y salones en
las aldeas cercanas los prepararemos
Hasta que el puesto de observación de
semeru declare que es seguro regresar a
casa cuando lo sea podemos pedirles que
regresen a casa pero si aún no es el
caso deben permanecer en nuestros
refugios y comienza ya la segunda fecha
de los octavos de final de la Copa del
Mundo Qatar 2022 con Francia ya
enfrentando a Polonia en el primero de
dos partidos en el segundo encuentro del
día la selección inglesa se medirá ante
senegal el campeón africano en busca del
pase a cuartos de final nuestro enviado
especial Juan pupiales nos contó más
temprano detalles sobre los países con
más representación de hinchas en este
mundial 2022 un evento futbolístico en
el que las autoridades estiman la
asistencia de más de un millón de
aficionados provenientes del extranjero
los aficionados del reino de Arabia
Saudita son la mayor representación de
visitantes en este mundial de Qatar 2022
según los datos publicados por la FIFA
hasta la fase de grupo 77 mil
aficionados de este país han acudido a
esta primera instancia y se hicieron
sentir Y de qué manera en los tres
partidos que disputó su selección
incluyendo esa sorpresiva Victoria
contra Argentina en su Debut en este
certamen Victoria que no fue suficiente
para que el reino avanzará a octavos de
final el segundo país con mayor
representación aquí en Qatar es la India
con 56 mil aficionados un país que vibra
por el Cricket pero en donde también hay
una pasión por el fútbol el tercer lugar
es para los aficionados de Estados
Unidos con 36,000 aficionados el cuarto
lugar es para los británicos para el
Reino Unido con 30.000 aficionados a un
país con una enorme tradición de fútbol
El quinto lugar es para una delegación
latinoamericana para México que cuenta
hasta la fase de grupos con 25 mil
visitantes visitantes aficionados del
Tri que no pudieron ver su selección
avanzaba octavos de final algo que no
ocurría desde hace 44 años sorprende la
ausencia de Argentina en este ranking
particular dado que en cada partido de
la albicelese hemos visto una nutrida
presencia de los hinchas de este país el
más reciente ejemplo en esa Victoria
contra Australia en los octavos de final
sin embargo si se hicieron sentir en el
partido con mayor número de aficionados
que hemos tenido en este mundial
hablamos del encuentro de la fase de
grupos entre Argentina y México
precisamente que contó con
88.966 espectadores un récord de
existencia en un mundial desde la final
de la Copa mundo de
1994 Eso sí este partido no es el que
contó con más escándalo por decirlo así
según estas estadísticas de la FIFA el
mayor partido el partido con el mayor
número de decibelios que hemos vivido
hasta ahora fue el encuentro entre
Uruguay y Corea del Sur en la primera
fecha de la fase de grupos
y además de Qatar los hinchas del fútbol
también están los ojos de los hinchas
están en Brasil donde la estrella del
fútbol sonar antes de nacimiento mejor
conocido como Pelé sigue internado en un
hospital de Sao Paulo y se encuentran
cuidados intensivos tras reportes no
confirmados de que había sido movido a
cuidados paliativos el deportista de 82
años emitió un comunicado diciendo que
se sentía fuerte y con esperanza el
mundo del fútbol y los aficionados
esperan su pronta mejoría Andrés
granadillo nos tiene más detalles
buenos deseos para el rey del fútbol el
estado de salud de Pelé crea
preocupación en todas partes del planeta
tras la noticia de su hospitalización
fue internado en el hospital israelita
Albert Einstein el pasado martes 29 para
una revaluación del tratamiento de
quimioterapia para el tumor de colon
Todavía está en tratamiento y el estado
de salud se mantiene estable futbolistas
y organizaciones del mundo esperan su
mejoría como kilian mbappe rivaldo
Junior la FIFA la conmebol o el equipo
Santos de Brasil en pleno mundial en
doha los fans del Astro no reconocen a
otro como él
significa mucho es el mejor del mundo no
tenemos ningún otro como Pelé
tienen a Maradona en Argentina Brasil
tiene a Ronaldo como el segundo mejor
pero Pelé es el primero el más
importante
Pelé de 82 años es considerado como uno
de los mejores deportistas de todos los
tiempos el periodista Patricio de la
barra en entrevista 24 analizó su
importancia deportiva la verdad es que
pelees Para mí fue uno de los mayores
iconos del fútbol mundial un jugador que
superó todas las marcas se superó marcó
más de mil goles incluso estuvo en
diversas partes del planeta Yo lo conocí
en Chile incluso cuando era pequeño y él
ya era un gran Astro en 1958 recordemos
que venció ese primer mundial y de ahí
para adelante se tornó para mí el mejor
jugador de o el mejor atleta de la
historia según el periódico fola de Sao
Paulo la quimioterapia del Astro fue
suspendida y ahora está bajo cuidados
paliativos y en otras noticias del día
mientras la invasión rusa de Ucrania
está a punto de entrar en su décimo mes
la ciudad de gersón en el sur del país
fue bombardeada el sábado en la noche
provocando una ola de incendios que
dejaron Al menos dos heridos en las
últimas semanas se ha recrudecido el
ataque en la región desde que fuerzas
ucranianas retomaron el control de su
capital lo que ha dejado a gran parte
del país sin electricidad mientras se
prepara para un largo invierno semanas
de bombardeos rusos sobre
infraestructuras civiles críticas han
dejado a gran parte del país sin
electricidad inclusive también sin
suministro fiable de agua millones de
ucranianos se enfrentan ahora a meses de
mal tiempo y temperaturas bajo cero con
sus ciudades y pueblos en ruina veamos
el informe
calinoffca Ucrania el invierno pasado
esta pequeña ciudad al suroeste de kiev
era el hogar de unas 5000 personas ahora
tras nueve meses de guerra está en
ruinas los pocos residentes que quedan
luchan por satisfacer sus necesidades
diarias
es difícil para todos quiero mi casa
quiero vivir en paz y que mi hijo y su
novia tengan un lugar donde vivir porque
ahora no tienen vida no es vida
se están construyendo rápidamente
viviendas de emergencia y será
necesarias las temperaturas invernales
en Ucrania caen a menudo hasta los 25
grados bajo cero y permanecen así
durante semanas al sur en gerson
recientemente liberada las fuerzas rusas
expulsadas siguen bombardeando la ciudad
mientras los trabajadores de
Electricidad se apresuran a reparar las
líneas eléctricas bombardeadas cuando
empezamos a reparar el bombardeo
comienza inmediatamente parece que nos
ven o que alguien les informa ha
ocurrido muchas veces reparamos las
líneas eléctricas y al día siguiente
tenemos que volver a repararlas
el invierno también ha llegado aquí los
residentes dependen de la luz de las
velas para iluminarse mientras que el
gobierno ha instalado tiendas de campaña
de emergencia a las que la gente puede
acudir para calentarse y cargar sus
teléfonos
Moscú ha respondido con semanas de
bombardeo sobre las instalaciones
civiles de Electricidad y agua luego del
éxito de la contraofensiva del ejército
ucraniano una campaña destinada a
quebrar la voluntad de la población de
seguir resistiendo y que según la ONU
puede ser un crimen de guerra
y de Ucrania pasamos a Francia en donde
los miembros del partido conservador los
republicanos eligen hoy a su próximo
líder una figura llamada a enderezar el
rumbo del partido que salió debilitado
de las más recientes elecciones frente
al movimiento de Manuel macron y la
extrema derecha tres candidatos compiten
para reemplazar a Cristian y Jacob el
favorito es el siotí quien ocupó el
segundo lugar durante las primarias
presidenciales el año pasado y está en
el ala más a la derecha del partido
también
compitelio un candidato más joven y más
centrista de ser elegido ha prometido un
relanzamiento del colectivo que incluye
cambiar su nombre y sede el tercer
nombre es una hoja de líder republicano
en el senado francés
alrededor de 1700 focas en peligro de
extinción fueron encontradas muertas en
la costa del mar caspio en dagestán
según las autoridades locales aún no se
ha establecido el motivo del deceso y la
cantidad de animales muertos podría
aumentar los especialistas de la agencia
federales de pesca de Rusia y la oficina
del fiscal ambiental están
inspeccionando la costa y recopilando
datos para la investigación de
laboratorio
y en Colombia el gobierno de Gustavo
Petro dijo haber alcanzado un acuerdo
con el grupo eln el ejército de
liberación nacional para el retorno de
indígenas desplazados a su lugar de
origen en los departamentos occidentales
de chocó y risaralda los diálogos de paz
con la única guerrilla que no ha
depuesto armas en el país fueron
suspendidos en 2019 tras un atentado a
una escuela de policía y retomados en
Venezuela el pasado 21 de noviembre bajo
el nuevo mandato de izquierda el jefe de
estado colombiano lo calificó como el
primer logro significativo en poco menos
de dos semanas de conversaciones el
primer punto de acuerdo que logramos con
el eln escasa una semana que llevan
estos diálogos es que se permite el
regreso de las poblaciones desplazadas
por esa organización de territorios
indígenas en veras a su resguardos con
garantía
de no repetición y de retorno y
terminamos esta Informativo en Australia
en donde la policía acusó de seis
delitos relacionados con terrorismo
aniel Christopher fraccion de 31 años
sospechoso de ser un miembro de alto
perfil del grupo estado islámico bracash
fue arrestado en Turquía en 2016 y
extraditado hace dos días a Australia
que en 2018 lo había despojado de su
ciudadanía las acusaciones en su contra
que incluyen participar en actividades
hostiles en el extranjero apoyar a una
organización terrorista y defender el
terrorismo conllevan penas que van desde
5 años hasta la cadena perpetua como él
las autoridades estiman que unos 230
australianos han viajado a Irak y a
Siria para tomar las armas desde 2012
con esto damos fin a este Informativo en
France 24 quédense con nosotros
[Música]